ん
[音楽]
さあ皆さんこんにちは
僕は指揮者です音楽家です皆さん
ベートーヴェンの光響曲大工してますか
[音楽]
ブービー賞
ブーブー言っは
ban なんてえっ ten 出るで
んでねぇ素晴らしい
イエスが家
脳はの
さあとずれんですけど皆さん
イエスが yes
脳がのて言えてますか
突然すぎですよね斎宮立ったかと思えば常なんですもんだと
まああの皆さん生活の中でどれだけの本音を
入れてますか
本音と言われてもピンとこないかもしれませんけど
私たちは日本の風習として物事に対して no を
はっきり言いにくい習慣がありますよね
相手に本音を伝えるって本当にこう勇気がいることだと思いますよね
相手に嫌われたらどうしようとか
あっスレイなことでたらどうをしようとかですねいろいろありますよね
例えばこんな経験ありますか
お父さん今度の日曜日一緒に遊びに行こうねー
今度ご飯でも行きませんか
帰りたいのにちょっと残業断れやったん
じゃあもう一回聞きますよ皆さん家2階へ
動画の本当に入れてますか
これじゃなくてもいいですあの責められたりすることもありません
んでもですね yes no が言えないからもしかしたら
心で苦しんでることを感じることもあるかもしれません
まあこれは一度屋根にどうこんな経験が誰にもあるかも知れませんし僕にもあります
もちろん
これはあのビジネスにおいてもプライベートでも一緒ですよねー
うん
日本語でどうやっても断定的に肺へと言えないと言いますよね
これが悪いことではないんです社交辞令が悪いというわけでもないんですよ
日本人の感覚で挨拶のように使っている言葉でもいいと思います
でもそれって本当にあなたの本命ですか
その気持ちがあなた自身を追い詰めたりしてません
脳ということが悪いわけではないのになぜか言えない
一度はこんな経験したことありますよね
もちろん僕もあります
入って言えないでしょ
いいえ
って言えないじょ
きっとね今日来られている多くの方がそういうような経験をされたと思います
でもですねこれって私たち日本人だけが感じることですかね
ではここでこれを世界の共通語である
英語にちょっと変えてみたいなと思います
考え方を変えるのじゃなくって
言語を変えてみるって考えですよ
さあではさっきのですねまああのお父さん今度の日曜日にとか
今度ご飯でも行きましょう残業を頼まれた
っていうところちょっと英語にしてみます最初のところ
さぁさぁて組 somewhere next sunday
will be used for 見るネクスタイム
iphone て込ん
bar アイアースキット米 bose あ
work 小幡 n お前がお前が知っ
これね聞いていただくと英語ではイエスノーっていうのがはっきりしていると思います
これは英語でしかできない表現感覚だと思います
例えば iphone ととかアイキャンっていうふうに通しから始まりますよね
英語は最初に結論が出ますそして結論が出てそれから
続きが
出てくるんじゃないかなと思います
英語で話すこと自体がイエスノーと自分の意見を持てる
言葉のツールになっているんですよ
日本はどうでしょうねぇ
文法として英語がほとんどであり英会話としての英語を積極的に使う人が少ないですよ
ね
これはあの単語飽きたかなとかこの文法
当てたかなとか何か言いたいかというとそういうこと関係なくもう中付いたカントリー
でもいいわけです&リーとかですね
いいですねはい
今堂 neo 話してもらったように終えようっていうのはすごく単純なんですよ
伝えたいことをそのまま伝えてくれば3グリでしょ
儲かるじゃん版塗りでつぁんなんとなくわからなくてもどこをつけるだけですよ
僕はの日本に生まれましたまあ不幸かじゃないですけど宮城県は気仙沼で生まれました
ね
さっきちょっとあの震災の話があってましたけれども
まあこの日本中の国ね素晴らしさがとてもよく分かっていますしこの私たちがしゃべる
日本語の奥ゆかしさと
日本語でしか伝えられないこともちろんたくさんあります
でもそれを否定する気はないんですけどまぁちょっとだけ
もったいないなぁと
思う時があります
自分の気持ちを素直に正直に伝えるとき
すなわちイエスえいえいえつはいえ脳はの塔伝えたい場合の英語を話してもそして
聞いててもとても率直で分かりやすい言葉ですよね
ここからポイントですよこれからの新しい時代を作るためにまず大切なのはい
自分を
認める
そして相手を認めます
それに不可欠なのは
自分の意思を相手に明確に伝えることじゃないかと
僕は思います
ね未定の格好ですけど僕はの指揮者としていろんな経験を
まあまだ若輩者ですけどあのしてきました
日本での活動はもちろんですけどまぁ海外でも活動します
で海外で活動するので逆にこう日本のよさっていうのを再発見します
日本の
素晴らしさを知ることができたのは海外に出たからなんですね
これ文化も
言葉も
全然違う国で
音楽っていうのはとっても大きな役割を果たすんですよ
もう日本語は難しいですよリハーサルしててもですねここ
1泊寝床ですか200どこできるんですかでもこれ海外に行くと僕見て落ち3
ok
これでいいですよー全国わかったッ
こういうだけしていますよ
音楽に国境はありません
ミュージウィザートワーズん
同じ音を聞いて同じ歌を歌う
これって素晴らしいコミュニケーションにつながるのではないかと思います
僕がなぜ音楽の話をするかそれはもう見ての過去の通りです
僕は音楽家ですし指揮者です
でもですねこういうふうに曲がって35なんですけど
35になってあの思うんですけど
まさか自分がこういうふうに音楽を仕事にするって子供の頃からしてみたらですね全然
こう考えつかないことだったんですね
だいたい僕はあんまりこう人と同じことをするのがあまり好きじゃないんですね
そして人と違うことをするのでやっぱこう
ため
には人から受け入れられない事もありますよね
またまにはじゃなくて多々ありましたのがいいかもしれません
まあそれがですねまぁ今正しかったかどうかというのは分からないんですけど
ただですねそれを受け入れてくれる仲間はいます
yes と言ってくれる人を前にするダメだよとかノーと言ってくれる人僕はですね
その両方ともとっても素敵な財産だと思っています
あの先ほどね最初に歌ってもらいましたけど
ベートーベンの第九
僕はですねこの大工を通して
まあ活動してまぁいろんな人に教える活動してるんですけど
第いくっていうのはですねあの大笠巻の第二ではなくて
まあのベートーヴェンが作曲した光響曲の9つ目なんでだいくって言うんですけれども
冷凍便が何を言いたかったかという
と音楽を通してみんな仲良くなろう
とこれ言っていますああこれはいいことだなと思ったので
じゃあ音楽したらみんな仲良くなるんだ僕思ったんですよ単純なのでですねじゃああの
子どもたちあのあってさすがにちょっとか赤ちゃんとかは難しいんですけどまぁ34歳
の保育園児からまあ僕みたいなあの青年とか
それからこうねおじいちゃんおばあちゃんの世代まで老若男女でみんなで練習して一生
懸命を覚えます
でこれを覚えますと一生大クってどこででも使えますし
3世代が集まるきっかけにもなる
一生涯のこれパスポートっていうのをゲットできるんですよ
おすごいですよね
音楽は何もない空気に振動を加えるので私たちは音を感じるのでこれはいわゆる物理
行為です
言葉以外のものを使って
気づいたらみんなおさじ気持ちになったり
これは刈り上げたりするんですよだからねほんと音楽っていうのはこう魔法みたいだな
と
思います
そしてこう音楽は人と人とを結びつける
コーディネーターの役割をするし
なんといってもですねー
言語を超越した感覚なんですよ
音楽は
だからこそ僕はですね皆さんに伝えたい
もしみなさんが海外に行くなら音楽と一緒に行ってみません
音楽は何よりも世界の共通語です
皆さんが号海外に行くっていうのでビジネスで行ったり遊びに行ったりとかですね
まあそういう色々あの理由はあると思いますけども音楽はセブすべて世界の共通
僕が言うから間違いないですそれ
そこで何かこう新しい出会いが必ず訪れると思います
イエスのそういう本音で言い合えるような素敵な人たちと皆さん
であってね本当の意味で世界の
みんなと友達になって欲しいと思います
こうやって皆さんで声をあげて
太鼓歌う世界と友達になる第一歩
イエスはいえの歯のと入れる第一歩かもしれません
では最初に歌えましたけど最近はちょっとこうドイツ語でフロイデシャネルげったる
うんけんとってるアウス ad gm
まあいろいろいろいろ言ってますけど
みんな仲良くなろうって言っていますドイツ語1回言われただけではわからないと思い
ますけれどもやってみましょう
さあ皆さん大きな声で
フロイデ生練馬ちょい知性の4位でシェネルゲってる文献
遠くてあぁセ d ズー
べいべていたんだぞ入れネームランド犬ええええ
どうもありがとうございましたもう一回 ok 状況はでしょ
さあこれでお答えして1中どうぞ
さあ入れ
ana
うんねんねえねえ
方がいいですよわーらーらー
ラララだラガー
玉出られぬ中
ありがとうございます
[拍手]